so where i left off in the last video i
just rewritten um the spring equation
and i just wrote you know force is mass
times acceleration and i was in the
process of just saying well if if x is a
function of t what's acceleration well
velocity is the derivative of x with
respect to time right your change in
position over change of time
and acceleration is is the derivative of
velocity or the second derivative of of
position so you take the derivative
twice of x of t
right so let's rewrite this equation
in those terms
let me erase all this i actually want to
keep all of this just so we remember
what we're talking about this whole time
let me see if i can erase it
cleanly that's pretty good
let me erase all of this
all of this i'll even erase this
i think that's pretty good
all right
now back to work
so we know we know that hopefully we
know that acceleration is the second
derivative of x as a function of t so we
can rewrite this as
mass
times the second derivative of x
so i'll write that as well i think the
easiest notation would just be x prime
prime
that's just the second derivative
of x as a function of t
all right i'll write the function
notation just so you remember that this
is a function of time
is equal to
minus k
times
x of t
and what you see here what i've just
written this is actually a differential
equation a differential equation and so
what what is a differential equation
well it's an equation where in one
expression and one equation on both
sides of this you not only have a
function but you have derivatives
of that function and the solution to a
differential equation isn't
isn't just a number right a solution to
the equations that we've done in the
past are numbers essentially or a set of
numbers or maybe a line but the solution
to differential equations is actually
going to be a function or a class of
functions or a set of functions so so
that's a it'll take a little time to get
your head around it but this is as good
as an example as ever to be exposed to
it and
we're not going to solve this
differential equation analytically we're
going to use our intuition behind what
we did earlier in the previous video
we're going to use that to to guess at
what a solution to this differential
equation is and then uh if it works out
then we'll have a little bit more
intuition and then we'll actually know
what the position is at any given time
of of this mass attached to the spring
so this is exciting this is a
differential equation
we when we drew the position our
intuition for the position over time our
intuition tells us that it's a cosine
function with amplitude a so we said
it's a cosine
omega t you know where this is the
angular
angular velocity of of well i don't want
to go into that just yet we'll get a
little bit more intuition in a second
and now now let what we can do is let's
test
this expression this function
to see if it satisfies
this equation
right
so what is
if if we say that x of t
x of t is equal to
a
cosine
of w t
what is the derivative of this x prime
of t
and you could review the derivative
videos to remember this
well it's the derivative of the inside
so it'll be that omega
times the outside scalar
a
omega
and then the derivative i'm just doing
the chain rule the derivative of cosine
of t is minus sine of whatever is in the
inside so it's
but i'll put the minus outside so it's
minus sine
of w t
and then if we want the second
derivative so that's
x prime prime of t
x prime prime of t we do this in a
different color just so it doesn't get
monotonous that's derivative of this
right so what's the derivative of we
take the derivative these are just
scalar values right these are just
constants so the derivative of the
inside is an omega i multiply the omega
times the scalar constant i get
i get
minus a
omega squared
and the derivative of sine is just
cosine but the minus is still there
because i have the minus to begin with
minus cosine
cosine of omega t
now let's see if if this is true so
if if this is true i should say i should
be able to say that m
m
times
the second derivative of x of t which is
in this case is this
times
minus a
w squared
cosine
of w t
that should be equal to that should be
equal to
minus k
times my original function times x of t
and x of t is a cosine wt
so a
cosine i'm running out of space wt
hopefully you understand what i'm saying
i just substituted x prime prime the
second derivative into this and i just
substituted
uh
x of t
which i i guessed as that
in here
and now i got this and let me see if i
can rewrite maybe i can get rid of the
spring up here i'm trying to look for
space i don't want to get rid of this
because i think this gives us some
intuition of what we're doing
one of those days that i wish i had a
larger blackboard
so let me erase
the spring
hopefully you can remember that image in
your mind and actually i can erase that
and i can erase that
let me erase all of this just so i have
some space without getting rid of that
nice curve i took the time to draw in
the last video
almost there okay
back to work
back to work make sure my pen tool is
right okay so what all i did
neat
is as i took
we said that by the spring constant
if you rewrite force as mass times
acceleration you get this which is
essentially a differential equation i
just rewrote acceleration as the second
derivative
then i took a guess that this is x of t
just based on our intuition of of the
drawing i took a guess
and then i took the second derivative of
it right this is the first derivative
this is the second derivative and then i
substituted the second derivative here
and i substituted the function here and
this is what i got and so let me see if
i can if i can simplify that a little
bit so if i rewrite there i get
minus
m
a
w squared
cosine
of w t
is equal to
minus k
a
cosine
of w t
well it looks good so far let's see we
can get rid of the minus signs on both
sides
get rid of the minus signs on both sides
get rid of the a's on both sides right
we can derive both divide both sides by
a
and do this in black just so it really
erases it
so if we get rid of a on both sides
we're left with that
and then so let's see we have m w
squared cosine of omega t is equal to k
cosine of omega t
so this equation holds true if what is
true
this equation holds true if
if m
w squared or omega squared i think
that's omega i always forget my
is equal to k
or another way of saying it if
omega squared is equal to
k
over m
or
omega is equal to the square root of k
over m so there we have it we have
figured out what x of t has to be we
said that this differential equation is
true
if this is x of t and omega is equal to
this so now we've we figured out the the
the
the actual function that describes the
position of that spring as a function of
time
x of t
x of t is going to be equal to we will
write about the
a and that's just intuition right
because the amplitude of this cosine
function is a
a
cosine instead of writing w because we
didn't you know we can i now write the
square root of k over m
the square root of k
over m
t
that to me is amazing we have now
using not too sophisticated
calculus solved a differential equation
and now can if you tell me at 5.8
seconds where is x i can tell you and i
just realized that i am now running out
of time so i will see you in the next
video